es momento de hablar de economía hoy
viernes santo- daniela blandón está con
nosotros en el estudio de daniela
comenzamos hablando de las tasas de
desempleo en eeuu que están cayendo a su
nivel más bajo desde que inició la
pandemia cover 19 hola santiago buenas
noches al cumplirse un año desde que fue
declarada esta pandemia de kobe 19 el
desempleo en eeuu está retornando poco a
poco a niveles habituales pero todavía
está lejos del 35 por ciento en que se
encontraba a comienzos del año pasado en
abril la tasa de desocupación se había
disparado el 14 7% y este mes marzo
llegó al 6% la más baja desde entonces
en el tercer mes del año se crearon 916
mil puestos de trabajo en este país esta
es la mayor cifra desde agosto del año
pasado pero todavía queda un largo
camino por recorrer
station después de un año de devastación
todavía 84 millones de empleos menos hoy
que en marzo pasado 84 millones y fui
formal demasiados estadounidenses han
estado desempleados durante más de seis
meses demasiadas mujeres han sido
expulsadas de la fuerza laboral el
desempleo entre las personas negras
sigue siendo demasiado alto y hay
noticias interesantes para los
productores de carne de cerdo en la
argentina que van a poder vender sus
productos en los emiratos a la vez pero
claro por las restricciones culturales
sólo a los extranjeros claro que si
santiago pues estos productores de carne
de cerdo argentinos van a poder exportar
esa carne refrigerada y congelada luego
de recibir un certificado veterinario la
cancillería destacó que si bien el
consumo de cerdo y sus productos
derivados se encuentra prohibido por la
religión musulmana los emiratos árabes
unidos permiten la importación de esta
carne para que sea comercializada y
consumida por los extranjeros que
residen en este país argentina el año
pasado duplicó sus ventas externas de
carne de cerdo en total exportó más
25 mil toneladas por unos 55 millones de
dólares ahora santiago planea incluir
dentro de sus compradores a emiratos
árabes que hoy en día es un su octavo
socio comercial hablemos ahora de la
industria automotriz muy afectada con la
pandemia del cobre 19 pero no por el
virus sino por la ausencia de chips en
el mercado mundial si santiago la poca
oferta de este elemento que es vital en
la industria tecnológica está generando
cada vez más distorsión los chips de
computadores alimentan una amplia gama
de productos que se están usando más que
todo en la pandemia pero este inesperado
repunte de la demanda de chips y su
consecuente escasez tuvieron serias
consecuencias si se las voy a enumerar
primero no se está produciendo la
cantidad de portátiles suficientes para
que los estudiantes aprendan desde casa
porque nadie se iba a imaginar que las
ventas de computadoras personales iban a
crecer después de una década en declive
segundo eso originó el retraso del
lanzamiento de productos como el iphone
12 el año pasado y también generó una
frenética carrera entre los compradores
de la
pocas consolas disponibles de
videojuegos como el playstation 5 pero
las cosas santiago han empeorado en las
últimas semanas expertos estiman que
entre enero y marzo
este fenómeno redujo la producción de
automóviles sólo en américa del norte en
unos 100 mil muchas fábricas están
cerrando ya no por la pandemia sino
porque no tienen chips para terminar de
armar los vehículos y el problema se vio
agravado recientemente por el bloqueo en
el canal de suez que dejó paralizados
contenedores enteros de chips que iban
de hacia hacia europa interesante e
interesante esta cifra que al menos
siete de cada diez empresas británicas
han interrumpido su comercio con la
unión europea después del break set
santiago esto lo dice un resultado de
una encuesta entre poco más de 1000
empresas de reino unido que se han visto
enfrentadas a un nuevo panorama desde el
primero de enero de este año cuando
entró en vigencia el divorcio con la
unión europea la encuesta llamada london
first de gerson jong concluyó que el 75
por ciento de las empresas experimentó
algún tipo de interrupción en sus ventas
hacia el bloque de países
la principal está relacionado con una
mayor burocracia la mitad cree que sus
inconvenientes para exportar van a durar
un buen tiempo y tres de cada diez dice
que su base de costos aumentó y muchos
han tenido que trasladar los costos a
sus clientes las bolsas no te dan la
operación por ser feriado religioso no
hay indicadores pasemos a la cifra del
día 185 mil vehículos eléctricos que
entrego tesla en el primer trimestre de
2021 más del doble que hace un año en
este fuerte repunte de las ventas
demuestra que el apetito por los autos
de lujo sigue intacto muchas gracias
daniela por esta actualización es todo
por el momento aquí en las noticias de
france 24 siga con nuestra programación
buenas noches
[Música]